bonsoir francesco rizzuto merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france la
ministre de l'intérieur qui donc a
dénoncé des scènes inacceptable à
bristol
la violence et le désordre commis par
une minorité ne seront jamais toléré dit
elle tout d'abord qu'on en sache un peu
plus sur cette minorité quelle est cette
minorité selon vous qui manifestent en
angleterre bonsoir ne fait aucun doute
maintenant parlons effectivement d'une
minorité de personnes quelques centaines
de personnes sur plusieurs milliers de
manifestants
nos caisses en l'occurrence de condamner
à ces scènes de violence durant bas mais
il faut se rappeler que cela peut être
choquant à voir
or minimes et nous avons vu la même
chose en europe en allemagne en thuringe
en france va donc exagéré le niveau de
violence véritable problème le véritable
sujet selon moi c'est un sujet très
grave c'est l'étendue de la restriction
du gouvernement avec d'une loi très
général il semble à restreindre le droit
des citoyens à manifester pacifiquement
de toute évidence il est important de
garder à l'esprit que nous sommes en
pleine qui s'agitait qu'une seule dose
sa distanciation social est il des
règles similaires devraient être
respectées le concernant a les
manifestations
les manifestations pacifiques qui sont
concernés si on commence à dire si votre
manifestation est trop brillante
alors on a le pouvoir de l'interrompre
un sujet de préoccupation le
gouvernement va peut-être trop loin le
meurtre de sarah evrard c'est ce qui a
créé la grande colère au royaume uni on
n'aura pas la recette jeune femme qui a
été agressé et tué par un policier c'est
cela qui a accentué ce sentiment
antipolis et il n'y aurait pas dû avoir
d'interdiction à manifester ça a mis de
l'huile sur le feu selon vous ben moi
cet incident ce fait est vraiment
tragique est terrible il a effectivement
été tué par un policier ce qui n'est pas
le sujet certains meurtriers une
personne de fins terrible qui a décidé
de tuer une femme sans défense
mais la question pour la police a pu se
protéger de fonds nous permettre une
manifestation pacifique suite à
l'assassinât de quelqu'un qui représente
la violence envers les femmes de ce fut
pour moi c'était un choix très difficile
pour les plantes
au vu de la frustration de la colère il
aurait dû laisser la manifestation c'est
poursuivre leur intervention aggraver la
situation
parfois la loi et ceux qui la font
abriter ce qu'ils font appliquer la loi
duff doivent adopter une approche
délicate
manifestation à londres heures et la
gestion par la police je ne pense pas
que m'ont causé ces violences à bristol
il ne faut pas
de mélanger je pense qu'il y à un niveau
de frustration s'est levé dans toutes
les strates de la société du havre ou à
cause de ce très long confinement et les
gens sont effectivement un frustré par
le manque de liberté que le gouvernement
attaque leur droit de manifester
pacifiquement cela mène à des explosions
comme on l'a vu au bristol
vous l'avez dit francesco raid auto
c'est un thème qu'on retrouve finalement
ailleurs en europe en france notamment
on est bien placé pour le savoir en
espagne est-ce que selon vous le droit
fondamental de manifester est il en
danger dans royaume uni mais aussi donc
dans les autres démocraties occidentales
il faut trouver un équilibre entre le
droit de manifester pacifiquement et le
contexte actuel et la santé oui la
sécurité du public
il faut pas comprendre l'objectif
l'objet de la manifestation du 2 août
je redoute t on souvent démunis et
ailleurs en europe
surtout peut-être aura unis car cela que
je tousse on arrive dans une situation
appuyé sur pluton dix ans la police
interrompre une manifestation parce
qu'elle est trop brillante parce qu'elle
est les perturbatrices les
manifestations sont brillantes les
manifestations au but
d'autres perturbatrice afin d'éveiller
les consciences de sensibiliser et avoir
savoir des manifestations bruyantes dans
une démocratie ce n'est pas ton
signature cela montre que le système
démocratique et aux mains
personnes qui souhaitent à plaire à
d'autres qui pensent que le droit de
manifester
le droit de ne pas être d'accord doit
être contrôlée voir limitée cela
m'inquiète
merci francesco rizzotto professeur de
droit européen l'université de réduire
d'avoir été avec nous en direct pour vu
de l'extérieur ce soir